what about
if uh a large company like
automakers4gm toyota came to george haws
or on the tech space amazon facebook
google
came with a large pile of cash uh
would would you consider being uh
purchased
do you see that as a one possible not
seriously now
um i would probably uh
see how much uh [ __ ] they'll entertain
for me
um and if they're willing to like jump
through a bunch of my hoops then maybe
but like no not the way that m a works
today i mean we've been approached
and i laugh in these people's faces i'm
like are you kidding
yeah you know because you're so it's a
it's so demeaning the m
a people are so demeaning to companies
they treat
the startup world as their innovation
ecosystem
and they think that i'm cool with going
along with that so i can have some of
their scam fake fed dollars
you know fedcoin i don't what am i going
to do with more fed coin
you know fat coin man i love that so
that's the cool thing about podcasting
actually is uh people criticize i don't
know if you're familiar with the
spotify uh giving joe rogan 100 million
and something about that and
you know they respect despite all the
[ __ ] that people are talking about
spotify
people understand that podcasters like
joe rogan
know what the hell they're doing yeah so
they give them money
and say just do what you do and
like the equivalent for you would be
like
george do what the hell you do because
you're good at it try not to murder too
many people
like try like there's some kind of
common sense things like
just don't go on a weird rampage of
yeah it comes down to what companies i
could respect
right um you know could i respect gm
never
um no i couldn't i mean could i respect
like
a hyundai moreso right that's that's a
lot closer toyota
what's your nah nah korean is the way
i think i think that you know the
japanese the germans the us they're all
too
they're all too you know they all think
they're too great what about the tech
companies
apple uh apple is of the tech companies
that i could respect apple's the closest
yeah i mean i could never subscribe it
would be ironic
oh if uh if comedy is
acquired by apple i mean facebook look i
quit facebook 10 years ago because i
didn't respect the business model
um google has declined so fast in the
last five years
you